you
[Music]
hi everyone welcome to the last session
of our workshop and to the last keynote
talk and key not talk in this case and
it's a great pleasure to introduce bill
Turin jerk who is a professor at MIT so
peter has a number of awards including
Paris Caracas award he also worked on
worked very politically unlike many
different areas including computational
high dimensional geometry data mining
streaming algorithms signal processing
sparse Fourier transform fine grained
computational complexity but most
recently he has become interested in
learning based algorithms and that's
what he's going to talk today about
let's welcome Peter
thank you right
hello everyone can you hear me well yeah
all right ok so thanks for coming and
thanks for the organizers for inviting
me it's a great pleasure to be here
thank you my second time at a Microsoft
Research the first time was right in
2000 when I was interviewing for a job
in the datamined group so has been a lot
of changes since then I think that all
of you guys were in a different building
and so on yeah it was a long time ago
so in this talk I would like to give an
overview that several people including
myself and when I say several people I
mean this man folks I have been pursuing
over the last few years and this is a
research focus on using machine learning
to improve algorithms right so not
necessarily machine learning to solve
you know AI problem computer vision and
so on but on using machine learning
problem to improve classic algorithms
along the lines that are we often see in
the basic introductory algorithms
courses and as I mentioned you know this
is a joint work with several people and
there's a match and you saw the Nakatomi
young yuan and Ali began this work like
all those people have been at MIT where
this work was happening
since then others went back to Denmark
and young went to China to start as a
tenure track professor at a university
alright so so here is the I would say
one slight overview of this talk and I
have an easy job because Elina I was
talking about you know very closely
related topics just yesterday
but I just for the record here is a you
know the basic idea so the starting
point of you know like the starting
point of all of this our classic
algorithms right so these are the
classic anchor is that many people in
this room including myself Alex and many
other people are working on and these
are the algorithm discourses you know
the data are you know they populate a
standard textbook and so on like CRS and
so on and the distinguishing feature of
the surgeries that they have a waste
case guarantees right so those are girls
you know have to be provably correct if
they're approximate are girls you know
we have to have a provable guarantees on
the approximation ratio you know
typically we also have you know
worst-case guarantees on dynamic time
and so on and did Lisa say I mean you
know these are you know Al Gore said
very useful like you know this is like
an underestimation statement however
over time you know people realize that
West case approach to Al Gore design has
some issues and then in particular you
know like from the perspective of this
talk the key issues that if you design
angles for the West case often those
angle does have a limited adaptivity to
inputs right because I what often
happens is that you know in applications
not all inputs are created equal right
like some inputs you know you know
appear to be simpler you know to solve
while some others are you know have
their right and you know what's his
guarantees you know by definition chill
the Unger it for the West case and
they're not always but often you know as
a result of this they don't exploit you
know easiness of hardness of input data
so there have been a lot
of approaches I mean this is not a new
issue right I mean the this issue have
me recognized for the last few decades
and there are a variety of approaches to
it fever of garden had a very nice
recent survey about our beyond West case
right about our various approaches you
know like smooth analysis and so on in
this talk I will focus on one particular
approach which you know one can dub
machine learning based approach and you
know here is you know the ideas to view
this approach of a good design as as a
machine learning problem right so in the
in the extreme case you know you could
think about algorithms or being
completion problem which is a function
right so this function has some inputs
you get some output so you can sample
the inputs train say neural network on
those inputs and then you know get a
solution to your computational problem
right and that this approach you know
that there are many many aspects of this
approach I will over overview some of
the immediate next slide this approach
works surprisingly well
right so for for many problems you can
actually get a better algorithmic
performance right measure as time
approximation and so on you know
essentially by using this type of
approach right but unfortunately in the
extreme it you know comes with the
fundamental drawback namely you know it
doesn't come with the Westies guarantees
and not necessarily on the running time
but even correctness right I mean you
know if you feed and by the way I don't
mean no worse case guarantees on the
leading proven itself I mean let I mean
worst case guarantees on the algorithmic
problem solved using machine learning
right you know because you know if you
if you train your data on some
distribution and then you try to query
it with some you try to run your
algorithm different distribution you
know like who knows what what what will
happen right you you have very little
control in many situations over over the
outcome so ideally one would like to
have the the best of both words right
that on the one hand you retain you know
the power of machine learning right
which allows you to adapt to easiness of
hardness of our particular inputs or
hardness or
classes of inputs but at the same time
we'd like to have some sort of a control
over what is happening right what you
cloud you know for one you would like to
have guarantees about correctness right
you know correctness you know you're a
girl should be correct right and you
know hopefully you should also have some
control of running time and other
parameters so this is the class of
algorithms that I will focus on in this
talk all right so as I mentioned you
know there has been a lot of research
along these lines over the last few
years and here is a overview slide right
it's a very rough of review slide and I
apologize in advance for you know work
that you know to people whose work
should be here but you know like I I
I forgot you know please definitely let
me know but you know to the best of my
knowledge the work in this space can be
roughly divided into four classes all
right so perhaps the first like the
first my knowledge example of this type
of approach holger design I came from
the as often referred to as an algorithm
figuration right so here the idea is
that you know how you have a algorithm
it's a well behaving algorithm and so on
but it has a bunch of knobs right you
know that there are some parameters you
know like you can think simplex for
example right you know see place you
know optimization algorithm but that has
many knobs that you can tune right you
can think about hyper parameters in the
ML lingo and you can use machine
learning in order to to optimize those
parameters to particular instance or a
particular class of instances alright so
there has been a work in this place for
for awhile and you know recently Rishi
Kapoor of garden and Nina ball can you
know gave us the article foundations to
you know to this our line of research
right using a back letting and so on so
this is a one kind of algorithmic design
approach to this
to this problem over the last few years
though there has been many other
algorithmic techniques and this is you
know like a rough classification of
those right so another approach of
incorporating machine learning algorithm
that one can call ml Oracle's right so
an ml or echo is like a little birdie
that's how you can ask questions when
you as an algorithm not sure what to do
right so this is a particularly useful
in online algorithms right we're in on
an angle is the whole point is that you
don't know the future right but you know
you might have some guesses about the
future if you ask the little birdie
right so so this approaches have been
incorporated in a few recent papers and
it also tells not to be useful for data
structures you know Bramson ground
search techniques and and so on
another type of approach is that somehow
one can call the land structures so this
was actually my entry points out to this
field
so here the ideas that are you know the
whole algorithm is essentially based on
a one mathematical structure like like a
matrix for example right or or a mapping
of some sort and typically these are
mappings of structures our joy at random
right but you know this is random you
can just learn it right and you know
here there's been a very long line of
research under the banner of our
learning too harsh you know starting
from the work by Hinton's
salahuddin off and more recently it has
been applied in a array of compressive
sensing by the by the some folks at the
last algorithmic approach that I'm aware
of is some yet one can called end to end
okay so this is you know you basically
sample the inputs you know run your
neural network and hope for the best
right and this are this approach
you know has been also very popular
recently and especially in the context
of optimization algorithms right so it
has been applied pretty successfully to
two problems like you know scheduling
and various combinatorial problems and
so on okay so this is a also like a one
slide overview of you know different
aspects of our using a Molina algorithm
you know again I apologize you know if I
missed any relevant works you know
definitely I would appreciate feedback
at the end any questions so far
all right so in this talk that I will
give two examples of our using machine
learning to improve outdoors and this
examples was fall into one example fall
into this class and one will fall into
this place between one and three seems
to be like very very fuzzy algún
integration alone structures between one
and three well it's far it's fuzzy
because you know it's it's not a formal
classification right you know like you
know I have a divide-and-conquer and
dynamic programming it's again even
informally it's alright well it formally
the idea it's mostly about the numbers
right you know so here the at least the
original motivation was to say you know
two might be 80 or hundred kilometers of
simplex right so so you really have no
right you can imagine like listening all
these knobs and and unique them right on
the other hand in this case I mean the
size of the structure is a comparable to
the size of the input right so you know
you can easily have I know one video
knobs right but yes I agree that you
know this is this is not a formal
distinction but at least this
distinction has been helpful to me right
in understanding what's what's happening
all right any questions so far
alright alright so in this talk I will
focus on land a learning-based approach
to one particular method for Algirdas
EIN which is a so-called linear sketches
let me just take a quick poll how many
people have heard about linear sketching
before okay thanks
alright so for the you know half of the
folks who haven't seen it this is a very
quick overview so you know sketching is
an approach to algo design and it works
where the input can be represented
either explicitly or implicitly by
either a vector or a matrix all right so
it's a pretty common case and the first
step that you do in our linear sketching
as you take your input and compress it
by multiplying it by some matrix this is
supposed to be a fat matrix right so
it's supposed to have more columns and
rows right which means that you know the
dimension of SX is a shorter than the
dimension of X all right so you
basically compress the input then once
you do it you perform the computation on
the sketch as opposed to on the original
all right so you know the potential
benefit is obvious right you operate on
a smaller dimensional input of course
the some mapping introduces some error
right so all of this need or desire are
always approximate and over the last
hour a couple of decades
this approach has been not very useful
in for designing a variety of angles
you know to the best of my knowledge
perhaps the first approach of this type
is through randomized dimensional
reduction right so you know tools like
Johnson leadership them and so on which
now essentially tells you that you know
if you are okay with a world perception
approximation you can just take your
high dimensional vector project it down
and then operate on the projected
version
all right so this has been very useful
for lots of things you know similarity
search linear algebra problems and so on
another class of algorithms for which
this approach has been useful as
streaming algorithms alright so here is
streaming calculus we have a long stream
which you can implicitly represent as a
high dimensional vector at that sketch
and reduces the size of this vector so
you can actually start right so so there
are there are many streaming algorithm
up of landscape of decays which are
followed this approach perhaps the most
prominent example of this approaches are
compress sensing where you know the
sketching is incorporated directly to
the hardware design right so you take a
photo you know or sense sense something
you know the hardware automatically
computes a sketch of your image right so
that you have something shorter and this
reduces the acquisition time and once
you have the sketch you can run software
you know among musicians I want to try
to recover the original size the
original input and last but not least
sketching has been also very used in our
linear algebra right so for especially
over the last 10 years or so you know
some of the most efficient a girl or
regression
lauric approximation you know Ridge
regression as I want have been obtained
using sketching
all right so you know this slide you
know shows that Elena's sketching is
useful so the question is you know can
we use learning rights to improve
sketching outcomes and you know that
there are potentially many approaches
but a very natural approaches so to try
to learn the matrix right because in
most not all but most sketching linear
sketching anchor it's you know you do
sketching using random matrix I mean you
know there are many different matrices
you know sparse dance sub sample the
Hadamard transform fashion additional
stress and so on but they are typically
random and there is a reason why they
are random right I mean it's very easy
to generate a random matrix often you
can multiply
vectors by this matrix efficiently you
know for example there are sparse and
thanks to various concentration
equalities you can often get West case
guarantees right so you get that control
over the approximation factor however
you know it comes with the advantage
right you know random matrices by we
very definition don't adapt to the data
right now with the random right in fact
you generate those mattresses without
even seeing the data right so with the
oblivious in the in the strongest sense
alright so a natural idea is to not
generate those mattresses randomly but
to lend them from examples and this is
certainly not a new idea so for example
in the context of a damaged a production
I mean people have been using you know
adaptive damage the direction way before
they use the random image the direction
I mean no PCI ISO map and I was talking
about ISO map yesterday right that said
you know to the best of my knowledge
this type of techniques are typically
generic and they are not designed for a
particular algorithmic purpose right and
an often they probably don't work right
so for example if you try to do a
nearest neighbor search right you know
one can often one can do a you know say
PCA right to reduce dimension but you
know PCA preserves the global structure
while in similarity search you care
about neighborhoods right because you
care about preservation of the distance
of some points at the nearest neighbor
right so the objective of PCI is at odds
to what you actually want to preserve
right so you know so this means that you
know if you want to use at the step of
techniques for algorithmic problems you
know you have to detail or you have to
design those reduction with particular
algorithmic tools in mind yes boolean is
right so yes so they are over are fine
right so there are many ways of doing it
right like I didn't want to get into
details right because I have many
options will you think random Gaussian
like each end
independent Gaussian you can also take
random signs right plus minus one so you
can take sparse matrix like that where
you know there are mostly zero but as a
random the signs every now and then some
of the notes you want to adjust this
matrix a particular type so in this work
I will look at matrix of a particular
type in fact this at this type is going
to be sparse matrices right the knobs
the many knobs that I will adjust are
the values of the same addresses thanks
any other questions all right all right
so so the so we would like to land this
as sketching was in the context of a
particular algorithmic application in
particular to ensure some sort of a
correctness or approximation guarantee
and now here to the best of my knowledge
the research has been my sparser and
again you know if i'm missing something
you know definitely that we know but to
the best of my knowledge the first
results of this type have been obtained
by re Mousavi and you know the rest of
the rich by any group in the context of
a compressed sensing right so in
particular they pointed out a very nice
connection between compressed sensing
and autoencoders all right you know in
out encoders you know you have the input
you compress it into something smaller
and then you recover it right so the
objective of compressed instancing is
very similar and they use this a
connection to basically show how we can
train the third in our mapping s using
machine learning type of techniques you
can do that without non-linearity is
because you can just design the
architecture of your auto encoder so
that basically this is the first layer
of weights right so you know this is the
the second layer of the hidden units
right and then the rest is a you know
decoder
so they you know so this is to the best
knowledge the first type of farm work on
this topic but you know as we have seen
sketching are useful for many
algorithmic problems so you know the
question that you know we ask ourself is
you know can you improve a Streamy
Calgary's or in algebra algorithms using
you know the star lens sketches approach
right and the rest of the stock assuming
time permits I will give you you know
example answers to both of this two
questions right so I'll give an example
as three McHale girls that are uses
learning to improve the sketches and
linear algebra I'll go to procure for a
low-rank approximation then again use
the sound learn sketches alright so
let's start from the streaming
algorithms all right so the problem that
we focused on is a so called a frequency
estimation problem this problem is
variants are known of their many names
you know heavy-hitter this is another
variant of it so it's a streaming
problem right so here the idea is that I
have a stream of data right you know
integers for for example and the
algorithm is allowed to make one pass
over the input and the goal is that at
the end of the stream where the
algorithm makes a pass then the sun-god
has to be able to give an estimation of
a frequency of any element right so this
elements are from some universe you so
at the end of the stream the algorithm
is a given you know an item index and
it's supposed to output an estimation of
the number of times the selamat occurs
industry all right so this is you know
pictorial presentation of the
functionality that the streaming
albergue has to provide after reading
the okay so this is a you know useful
problem in many applications right I
mean
housing generally speaking is useful
right I mean you know other thematic
right so the classic motivation for this
is a network measurements right you know
packets with Network you want to
radically count them to figure out
what's happening in caballo
you know people count k-mers right so to
understand the structure of a genetic
sequences not useful in machine learning
and another application now of course
you know if you look at this problem
it's super easy if you have enough space
right because all you do you see an
element you increment the corresponding
entry but once you start dealing with a
massive data you want to use super sub
linear space right and then the problem
becomes much more interesting and there
are many solutions to this problem that
use a sub inner space approximate
solutions whose programs use a sub inner
space developed over the last two
decades or so and in this talk I'll
focus on one two examples the first one
is the so called the common algorithm
how many of you have seen count mean
okay all right so just gonna do a very
quick overview right this is a count
mean in a nutshell right the basic
algorithm essentially just takes the
whole universe of elements and they're
hashes it into a smaller universe which
can be stored directly nice we prepare
the cerrado hash function now you know
you typically don't actually have a
random hash function you use some pseudo
random hash function and I - to be able
to store it and you make encounters for
the hashed array such that you know each
entry contains the sum of the
frequencies that are mapped to this
entry right so it's a very easy to
maintain it right anytime you see an
element you just hush it increment in
order to estimate the frequency of the
element you know again you take the
element rush it and you return the value
of this counter right so this is a
essentially the whole algorithm
I'm saying essentially is because you
know typically you don't have just a 1/2
table and you have several hash tables
right and and then you combine these
estimators using the MU estimator but
you know from perspective of this talk
I'm just going to skip it so this
algorithm has a bunch of our nice
properties for one it works with both
insertions and deletions right you know
it sessions increments deletions
decrement right so so it's a very
flexible board right it also has the
nice property that I'd never
underestimate right because you know
staff hashes to this entry
now if something else hash is to this
entry
this introduces noise but the noise is
only positive right so you you never
underestimate which also has a nice
property so it's a wide use use an
algorithm but it's not the only one in
the space and another quite similar
algorithm called a count sketch and here
the main difference is that arrows have
signs right so you consistently multiply
each frequency by a sign which means
that when you add those frequencies AB
you know arrows can cancel out because
they are not all positives you know
their pluses and minuses all right so
you know counts cash typically has a
smaller error but it doesn't have you
know for example this property right so
depending on the situation people use
one or the other
all right so this is the standard count
sketch or count mean so let's see how we
can try to use machine learning to
improve the performance of this our code
but before we do it it's a perhaps
helpful to just do a like a mental check
and see like do we expect a machine
learning to find some structure that we
can exploit right like for example if
this you know the if the stream is just
a bunch of random numbers you know they
don't have structure right so presumably
we are not going to prove anything
if we just have a stream of random
numbers right so let's go to have some
mental check you know whether in the
typical data that people use this
algorithm structure that
potential can be exploited I do know
like if you think about it for a minute
or two you know it's clear that at least
in principle there is a structure the
tech house from the idea of a stream
elements in many applications right so
for example for we're data it's now that
our longer words okay less frequent
all right so just by looking at the
length of the world you know we can have
some noisy prediction of whether you
know element is a frequent or not and
similarly for network data you know
naturally some IP addresses you know are
more popular than others my exception
jeans and so on right so so you know at
least in principle there is some data
there's some information in the in the
data and you know if we have a machine
learning algorithm
lens patterns that potential we could
use them to improve the algorithm in
particular we could try to use it to
avoid collisions with the heavy items
right because if you have an some
element and some very heavy element
collides with it this creates a fairer
right so if somehow we could reduce
number of collisions between you know
heavy elements or heavy elements and
other elements then you know this would
potentially help us reduce the total if
you separately if your hash function
according to all things yes also
prevents collisions between infrequent
infrequent lengths k and k plus 1 right
so that's that's true
unfortunately the well so yeah right so
the depending on the objective function
that you want to optimize right you you
might either want to reduce the
collision between two heavy items versus
infrequent right so for the objective
function that now we're gonna is here
this seems to be the key issue but one
could imagine like if you wanted to have
you know other guarantees you know you
could imagine doing also that right the
problems that are in many of the streams
you know vast majority of items are
infrequent items right so that we have
to collide at some point right so you
know we can detect it but you know we
cannot do anything about a pigeonhole
principle all right so so here is our
our P approach to put machine learning
in the in the hashing algorithm is
inspired by a recent paper across kettle
on learned bloom filters and the basic
idea is to use past data you know you
know from from earlier time and so on to
train America a fire that attempts to
detect heavy elements right and then we
use that decisions made by discus afire
you know to decide you know and we treat
heavy learners Samuel differently okay
so in particular here is the flowchart
of the algorithm so after we train the
same Oracle based on our path data then
I given a new stream element right we
run it through the Oracle and if the
answer is that this element is not heavy
then it just goes to the standard
sketching calculate like like out mean
on their hand if this element is
predicted to be heavy then we assign a
unique bucket to it right now by signing
Kunik bucket we know that it's not going
to collide with anybody else right so so
this is the benefit right this guy you
know the heavy heavy hitter is not gonna
induce collisions but there is a price
for it because you know if you have to
store things in unique package then you
know we use more space right we we need
the you know space to store the hash
tidy and the count and you know and of
course you know we can you know if we
start everything as unique package then
we are not setting any space right so so
basically there is a trade-off and yes
from tool every words to less using like
compress dictionaries and stuff like
that so it doesn't matter too much well
you need a count and you need some sort
of ID right side you probably can
yes Yogi's are short yes well the IDS
already compressed right soso dislike to
words you know basically accounts for
that like 1 plus epsilon work but it's
still like so I don't know how to get
one perception because they are you know
multi-step right so we have to count you
have to maintain the count and yeah okay
but maybe maybe you can alright so so
that's essentially at the whole
algorithm and you know in the context of
the intro to this talk you know the
important thing to observe is that this
target actually inherits Wesley's
guarantees on the correctness from this
are good here right because in the
extreme case if your predictor is a
completely you know goes nuts right and
I just start assigning unique buckets
you know to LMS which are not heavy you
know as long as you limit the amount of
space that this unique buckets can take
you know this our goal it still has some
non-negligible space and you know
basically the whatever you you were sees
guarantees you get for this algorithm
you know they also apply to the who
lockers right weaker elements which are
which for here are estimated exactly so
there is no error lms that fall here you
know have exactly this error the same
error as induced by this right now of
course you know it can happen that you
know if you allocate a fair amount of
memory here you know you you cannot
allocate this memory here right which
means that you will lose you know some
approximation right your approximation
it's not gonna be as good but still you
have some control you know over the
quality of that right even if the Oracle
goes completely nuts and you know just
misclassifies everything all right so
this is the algorithm is a relatively
simple so you know so the questions that
how does it work so we did two types of
experiments I mean one type of
experiments on two data sets the first
data set is a stand
network traffic data set consists of
basically a bunch of packets we looked
at there one hour of traffic you know
the data set contains 30 min your
packets per minute we use the first few
minutes for training
you know just literally took the the the
signal of packets you know computed
heavy hitters and that trained the
machine learning Oracle to you know
attempt to predict whether element is
heavy or not and the rest is used for a
validation testing another set is the
American line query data set you know
here you know it's a bunch of queries
collected on birthdays so we used again
first few days for training and the
remaining four for testing this is the
log log scale distribution of the
frequency of those elements after
sorting right from the most frequent to
the least frequent which is gonna be
irrelevant later now how do we train
this Oracle we tried a bunch of things
and in the end we just start with the
recover to our network I mean can you
attract makes sense for this type of
queries right because you know they have
different lengths right so you cannot
say use a feed-forward networks in this
case you know they don't necessarily
make much sense and in fact we you know
in principle in fact you know we we
actually started from a decision trees
and we got a very good results here
the problem is decision trees is that
you need lots of space deputy big right
Sumida lots of space to store them and
just want to start safe space you know
it kind of defeats the purpose right so
in the end we just decided to use the
same you know set up for for both of
them
and last but not least in the context of
your question right so the arrow fashion
we try to optimize as this one alright
so this is the average error weighted by
the frequency of the element one way of
thinking about it is that you know this
is minimizing the average error or if
the elements are sampled proportionally
to the frequency right like the elements
are if the queries
you know to the frequency are sampled
from a distribution proportional to the
original frequency all right now if you
knew this frequency and if it's
different if you knew the Aquatic
frequency and it's different than this
one you could put a different number
here right but you know this is what we
did a factory with this this kind of
means that the distribution of the
queries is the same as the distribution
of the data right to the common
assumption in this situation alright so
so these are our results right so here
you see four charts two charts for
Internet traffic to charge for a quad
estimation for each data set you see one
a chart for count sketch one for count
mean and the most the two most important
plots here are the blue one which is the
standard count sketch and red one which
is our learned count sketch right or or
count mean and so on so you can see that
you know indeed we can improve the
trade-off between the space and error
sometimes you know by like a factor of
two or so the improvement is are better
for this data set on this data set right
so in procore here you see that the
improvement of the red over blue is a
fairly unlimited if this are these are
sample minutes from the future right so
what are the other two curves
well this curve this orange dotted curve
is another it's a similar algorithm pool
lookup table to implement the to detect
heavy hitters all right so here the idea
is that we take the whole data set
computer heavy hitters and only store
list of heavy hitters right so there is
no journeys ation of any kind and you
know you can see that this improves the
space but not as much as learning right
and we conjecture that input call for
internal traffic estimation this is
because you know often traffic comes
from fixed domain but with
or different IP addresses right so what
matters is the prefix of the IP right
and you know the lookup table doesn't
you know basically account for it right
while the the Oracle can just learn to
ignore the the suffix right the
recipient bit of the IP addresses okay
at the last curve right the the green
one is a special I wish for thinking
what would happen if we have an ideal
Oracle right which are always tells
between heavy elements and not heavy
elements right and if we had such an
Oracle we could improve the space even
further by a lot but you know of course
it's a bit of a science fiction because
the goal of this program is to estimate
the frequencies right so of course if we
knew the frequencies we could estimate
them right now it's not completely
stupid because this Oracle just assumes
that you know that we know exactly the
threshold you know heavy or not right
but still you know it's not realistic
that means that okay if we have a better
estimator we could improve things and
this is pretty much all data I had to
say about the experiments I should
mention that the space here includes the
size of the s5 before in many cases you
can distinguish in a final way not just
between the heavy details with life
heaters but you have several sizes yes
your world so in your analysis of the
ideal Oracle or I might want to say that
you know in which kind of bug back in
time sure yeah yeah that's a very
interesting idea so we we thought about
it a little bit we couldn't make it work
so that improves things that there is
some evidence that it would perhaps
surprisingly not improve things
asymptotically but that could
potentially improve the constants or or
or maybe if you modify the algorithm I
so actually I will I will talk about the
next slide yes but yes I mean this is a
very simple algorithm principle we could
imagine yes
seven minutes how much storage is that
like so this is this is done offline how
much storage you need a basically you
need to the the most of the storage is
taken by taking your data set and just
find the heavy hitters exactly right and
then you just each element at this point
becomes label and then you use as much
have as much storage as I know Python is
using tests of deployment you know like
the way I think about it is you train it
for example once per day say overnight
right and then you use this Oracle for
the whole day right or or or something
on this line but yeah I mean like
towards the add you know training takes
time right so yeah at the end I have a
discussion about the cons of just
approach so that's one of them one of
the motivations or like such it sketches
on the context of heavy hitters is to
kind of like do burst detection or
something like this right so for like
did you try instances like this or where
actually there is something unknown
burst and which you totally do not learn
during so so we didn't bells of tection
like in in that works so we didn't look
at it in carefully and you know in part
because you know our goal wasn't you
know really to improve state of the art
network monitoring tools right
our goal was to determine whether
standard streaming algorithms can be
improved you know using machine learning
right and you know the reason for that
is that you know like once you start
looking at the very particular
application so you know we are using
this data sets to test the quality of
the algorithm but we don't necessarily
you know we certainly are not claiming
that you can use this angled over bottom
you know in the network measurements
again I have a discussion about that at
the end well you know there was a
question of time and so on right so all
right so very quickly about our attempt
to understand what was happening
particularly so to this end we modeled
the data you know using the Sofia
distribution right that in the sorted
order the frequency of the Eiffel EMA is
proportional to 1 over R I this
assumption is a it is not be true for
AOL you know it's somewhat less true for
this data right because it was true this
would be a straight line and you have to
squint a lot you know to to see a
straight line yeah right but you know
it's a it's an assumption and we look at
the accounting Algar it like in the
later work we also analyze count sketch
and this is roughly what we were able to
show right so once you fix the
distribution you know you can analyze
the cut mean algerie tie exactly and you
can do the same thing for the algorithm
and Oracle so here in this table I'm
showing the analysis assume with
Oracle's perfect if it's not then the
basica will get interpolation between
these two right depending on the
propriety of X so the actual formulas
don't necessarily matter and what
matters is that the difference between
them as you can see in red you know here
you have well you have two logs here you
have two logs here but here one log is
of N and then and here both logs are of
n over B when B is the number of packets
right so basically this means that are
in the high accuracy regime where the
star n over B is thought to be small
like n over B is the compression ratio
right the compression ratio is a little
bit small
you know you can you you get the
improvement because this is constant Y
this is a look at it and this is
asymptotic analysis but you know it it
appears that
capture the you know what is happening
in the same algorithm have enough time
to give an intuition behind it but uh
you know if you have any questions that
you know offline and how the one thing I
would like to mention is that you know
here we get actually a pretty strong
lower bound in the sense that you know
we we show that any even if you use
arbitrary hash functions which is
completely designed for a particular
dataset as long as your data comes from
distribution you cannot improve this
bound right so so even if you have you
know like you know that did something
more elaborate on you know putting some
things in separate buckets and the rest
together at least asymptotically would
still pay this much and this is like a
greedy type of argument right that you
know if elements are very happy that you
always gain by putting them in a
separate bucket alright so I have like
15 minutes left
I think 1818 okay stuff like waiting so
if you can see the rather power loss
with like odd exponent then what is the
one the hardest so this different the
farthest case or well we didn't do
careful examination I mean if you have
some other alphas then instead of log
and you get some dependencies of alpha
constants in this location I'm able to
mention yes another version of this
problem in which the elements are not
chosen for my random distribution right
but form a pseudo random distribution
okay this often happens in cryptography
that there is some uniform probability
distribution with some pink right your
time to find it so I published several
years ago the conference shows that in
this case you don't need any memory in
order to find the heavy details okay
because you're basically using the fact
that you can use the control algorithm
every
those which are going to close the cycle
I see oh that's that's very interesting
actually if you're serving so just to
clarify that we are assuming is zipfian
distribution but in a deterministic
sense right so so this stream here is
not generated stochastically right we
just assume that after you count after
you compute the histogram the
frequencies then this is roughly what
what you see right you know essentially
what this is what the size is that the
in curve in plot like this you know you
get the line of slope minus one all
right so that's the assumption but in
PowerPoint is still taken all right so I
think that now my time reduced to like
15 minutes right 16 all right okay well
I guess you know counting correctly is
important okay so let me move on to the
second the classifier is probably try to
speed it up and this is a algorithmic
approximation you know I'm sure that all
of us know what it is but this is just a
recap right you have the matrix you can
decompose into a product of you you know
Sigma and V right you know U and V are
also normal matrices this is the acronym
and you know this is a huge this that
comes in has a huge number of
applications and properties very often
what people do is you know they take the
you know just top eigenvalues right so
they truncate everything that's it okay
and in values and you know it's a basic
fact that if you do it then you get the
best rank a approximation to the
matrices right let's say respect to
frobenius know right and you know
naturally this is used for compression
and you know and there are many other
applications all right now especially
over the last couple of decades
this matrices became pretty large right
you know recommendation systems and and
so on so the standard cargo rates start
to get somewhat slow in particular if
you just wanted to do you know like full
the composition to be in cube
all right you know that's an Cuba's a
lot so he said you know people develop
approximate algorithms there are various
ways of firm with approximation this is
one of them
right so you still want to output low
rank matrix but you don't necessarily
exist on a minimum the best rank
approximation but you know up to one
plus FC and you know it's it is Nabal to
expect that you can do it much more
efficiently than computing the exactly
and it did over the last 10 years or so
there has been a lot of work in a TCS
community and numeric our in our algebra
community and so on
I decided some of the papers on this
topic there's probably hundreds of
thousands many or most of the saengil
that uses some form of a linear
sketching and you know if you want to
know more
David Woodruff has a very nice survey
about other circles and you know it's
it's not just a low-rank approximation
you know there are many other venerable
programs you know read version and so on
that you can approach using this tool
the automation of also this are going to
use linear sketches you know again these
are sketch matrix you know can come from
several different it can be of several
different types now in this talk I will
focus on sparse matrices yes all right
so it's mostly zeros but you also have a
few non zeros which are random cells in
particular we focus on a one of the
earliest algorithm and this is a
streaming algorithm price it's not
necessarily I mean it improves over time
it proves the time but that mostly
focused on improving the space and the
actual algorithm portent because I will
not really use this algorithm but this
is just for an overview you know how
such a good like in the first pass you
compute the sketch write the product of
your sketch matrix times input matrix
then you you know or to normalize it
then you do a second pass right to
project a on V and then you perform a
computation and return the us
so the main think that we need to know
about this algorithm is that all it does
it stores sketches you know si and and
then it stores a times VT right and the
size of this is a basically proportional
to M M is the number of rows of the
sketch matrix so the shorter sketch the
less you need to start right and in
theory this sketch length can be made K
over epsilon where K is the the
approximation that you are looking for
now technically this applies to dense
matrices but I think something very
similar has been developed for sparse
matrices as well
all right so how can we learn this are
sketching matrix right so you know so we
are you know doing the natural thing
right so we take a bunch of a data set
of our mattresses like some sample
mattresses then we find the sketch
matrix which are minimizes the
approximation loss all right so this is
you know the output of the sallows
question woodruff algorithm right was
well define was to give it a sketch
matrix and the input matrix here is the
you know the original matrix right so
what we want to minimize this you know
average over the samples error so this
is a well-defined optimization problem
and you know if you solve this problem
then we can use the sketch matrix you
know in the future right as long as we
the mattresses come from the same
distribution all right so so that's our
basically what you do now this is a
well-defined problem but doesn't mean it
can be solved efficiently and actually
we don't know how to we don't have like
we don't have a clever way of a solving
it right so basically oh yeah I should
match that we use okay so first of all
we use a sparse matrices and thus we
don't quite know how to optimize over
support right because support is
discrete now we just choose those
mattresses those
these positions at random we optimize
the values all right so that's our one
simplification at this point you know
the problem you know it becomes amenable
to say graduate design now we still need
to differentiate this loss respect to
you know s and for some reason it turns
out to be tricky to do in a pie talk in
part because this involves angle value
computation so in the end basically we
represented as video computation as a
sequence of power methods right and
power methods you know are naturally
differentiable right so so at the end we
managed to differentiate this thing and
then just around stochastic gradient
descent we have one non-zero column they
are not steady large matrices actually
they are not low rank fantasies they're
arbitrary matrices there are example
inputs to the problem is to have some
structure so that you do naturally
right so it might be this hard this is
gonna answer the question right so what
are the type of data says that that we
looked at so we looked at the videos
where each matrix is a frame in a video
right you know this is example frame
from a logo video on on YouTube we also
look at the hyper spectral images and
this is a data set that curves
information 3-valve right you know you
know these are some of the details right
so we've some of them for training
testing we optimize the matrix size and
once we optimize the matrix size you
know we test it on again samples from
the same distribution and we compare it
to the performance of the random
matrices didn't ask you a question okay
all right so so this is the type of
results that we got so here we are
comparing there are three curves the top
curves are for sparse and dance random
matrices this is the curve that we get
for the land in matrix right and this is
as a function of a number of
measurements for k equal to 100 and this
is a test error in the log log scale in
the log scale all right so you can see
that are you know indeed that unique the
matrices helps which is you know perhaps
not surprising right because I mean it
has to help by definition right we are a
graduate descent right so it's a descent
not ascent right so so it has to be
better but you know it improves things
by you know potentially quite a lot
right so depending on the data set you
get a different performance right this
is for tag this is for hyperspectral is
for MIT logo not surprisingly you know
MIT logo is a very simple video right so
it's not surprising that you know there
is some structure that are you know from
a few video frames you can discover that
you can use to optimize the schedule if
there's nothing to do with the thought
but I mean it's maybe not us okay let's
take it offline right because I think I
have like only five minutes left or so
okay so so that's how you know that's
that's nice however you know steal this
you know this algorithm or satisfy our
this is the data that are you know even
if the prediction is completely off you
know we still want to have some
correctness guarantees so there's a very
simple solution which is to combine land
sketch with random rows and you know
there are various ways of combining
these two solutions but not the simpler
is just literally combine them and run
it using the same algorithm
and here comes you know and here we have
like the only lemma in the paper which
says that augmenting a random set of
rows with arbitrary patrollin matrix
cannot increase
the error of this Arcana alright so you
can think about as a sketch mo not
monotonicity so the proof of this is
really simple but the property itself is
non-trivial because there are other ask
algorithm this problem which don't have
this property right you know here this
property house because essentially we're
only using the kernel of the summit it
is you know then adding more rows to the
to the matrix you know just restricts
the solution even more right so so you
can you know is the argue that you know
you you cannot increase the error but
it's not a universal property for all
algorithms and if you do it you know
this means that the algorithm here is
the worst-case guarantees from out of
course you know the fact that you are
using some random measurements means
that you cannot use them for for
learning right so you potentially can
lose some but you know still we you know
we did some experiments right we use a
pure land matrixes purely random
matrices and mix it's like 50/50 and you
know you can see mixed are somewhat
worse but not much worse than than
learned right while still you have some
guarantees here you know random of
course you have full guarantees but they
don't work as well so you know it's
serious this is like a pretty reasonable
approach to inject some whiskey's
guarantees to the cell and our goals
right in this place called case is very
simple just add a few random times all
right so to conclude I talked about land
sketches and you know two papers I'm
sure that you know they can improve
things you know for streaming frequency
estimation low-rank approximation Apple
quad you know like I mentioned that all
of them have the failsafe options right
so you always get some guarantees so we
are working on using you know this type
of approach for other problems and in
particular in a joint work with ya and
Ilya and the tile I think all of which
here we have work on using machine
learning to improve local sensitive
hashing we're also working on trying to
improve the runtime of low-rank
approximation
how to improve space but to improve run
time we have to improve more complex
sketches write select sketches from 2 to
2 sites so we are working on it but it's
the work in progress and it associated
lots of questions perhaps you know the
main two are eccentric complexity right
so you know there are there is a toolkit
for trying to figure out how many
samples we need to to estimate things as
per Nina's talk we haven't done it yet
because analyzing this for you know
eigenvalues is a little bit tricky it
will be also very nice to minimize the
satisfaction the time machine earlier
you know professionally right as opposed
to just try to dump it in Python and see
what happens they are the hope is that
this potentially has some clean
formulation right and you know maybe one
can even optimize it with some
guarantees alright so we don't we don't
have it yet but you know we are working
and last but not least you know just
some summary thoughts right so like the
way I think about using ml in algorithms
that you know it's a it's a another
technique right I mean you have divide
and conquer you have a diamond
programming you know we have other
technique so you know you could imagine
ml or a course or or so on you know as
being another tool tool in the Algirdas
EIN portfolio but you know one has to be
mindful of the cons of this approach
right the pros the thai folk was done in
the talk is better performance but you
know there is lots of cones right you
have to try this fink which takes time
in the country of streaming
Algar it if you want to update right
you're streaming algorithms you have to
run a small neural network if you happen
to have the TP or GPU is fast if you
don't it's not right so and of course
you get different guarantees right you
know which are more learning time than
West case unless you inject some West's
guarantees directly but overall this is
a interesting at least I find
interesting topic so last semester with
Costas we taught a course at MIT several
people here in the audience
we invited speakers so thanks for coming
the slides are online so you know if
you're interested slice and scribe notes
are online so if you're interested take
a look and there are lots but at least
you know we hope that this type of study
will give some insights into classic
algorithms all right because you know
that would be also very interesting up
and that's it thank you any questions
can you say again the part where you
have the mixture you talked about car
shirt for the low drag out for the when
you have this plot with the mixture case
sure it doesn't give up too much in
terms of performance it well right so
basic is set of arrow or being 0.1 or
example here you get 0.2 what you do get
guarantees for this case because and
this discounts from through this lemma
here which tells you that you know even
if you just completely ignore your
length matrix and just focus on so you
definitely get the guarantees we just
use the half which is random right now
what this lemma says is that augmenting
randoms you know stuff with something
else doesn't decrease the error you will
improve like you observe yeah no so this
definitely doesn't guarantee about the
improvement all it says is that it
cannot be much worse than yeah I guess
this is for 20 measurements if you put
10 it's gonna be lower right so whatever
you get guarantees was that the
measurements you know they also apply
here all right so you get some you know
guarantees but of course you don't get
guarantees that you get improvement
right random matrix there's a near in
the neighborhood of that matrix there's
a good guy that
No
yeah yes when you mentioned that refer
to this whole idea of algorithmic design
and embedding machine learning right now
what I want to ask you is you know when
you feel in the field of politics
science has focused on approximation
algorithms for intractable problems and
right now in that field there is this
sort of I get that you want assignment
to negative a garden will have some
approximation ratio to the optimal
solution to the problem all right so is
there hope of being able to tell of
similar results when doing machine
learning because effectively what you
are going to do is you're going to
optimize that one read slightly modified
algorithm
what were some types of data right and
this is what is optimized for right when
the data doesn't come from with the
assumptions are not when you have a
different kind of matrix that doesn't
come from the right solution writers
right then you will have either but you
bound an error I see so let's see so so
first of all in the context of
approximation on your front we had
problems usually talk to Nina because
that's that's what you know she's like
all clustering and other problems right
I mean she she would talk about some of
them recently I I think the context of I
using this methodology to to machine
learning I use the distinction is you
know whether you apply this to machine
learning to the training algorithms
right so that's you know letting to
learn essentially right or whether you
try to get guarantees for the you know
classification you get at the end right
so classification you get at the end I
don't even know how to formalize it
because you know if you the goal is to
detect faces right um it's not even
clear what the worst-case guarantees
would would mean right because you know
this is not you know it's not the total
function
right I mean it's it's not even fully
defined right as a possibility you know
the ranks of the matrices were between
two to ten that's it all right and n is
large right now later you have tons of
machine learning we have a big model
that has been optimized for that range
of Frank's right but new data now we
have a matrix that is ranked wing right
so it's the performance of this lord L
God there will probably be worse than
originally it's good it could and that's
why you know that's basically why we you
know that that's a major concern right
and you know like our solution and you
know there could be others is to
basically open the sketch with some
actual you know random gross right for
which you know there are lots of
guarantees right you know as well as
spent this book right so so so that's
basically our our solution right because
I agree you know it's a buck with the
others
okay let's thank the speaker again
[Applause]